facing against the left-hander julio
urias hot left-handed pitcher for the
dodgers who is young talented and uh
making another start he puts away tapia
on three pitches to open up the ball
game now the first inning's really been
his only hiccup this year ninth era
coming into this
shortened season so in steps trevor
story here comes the 3-2
misses away and stories aboard with a
one-out walk and now nolan
the story took off but there is the pick
off but the throw over to lux he can't
glove it and tag him so story is safe so
runners position early for the rockies
throws a breaking ball nolan smokes it
to the left but just to the warning
track
aj pollock is there and story was
tagging up two away charlie blackman
digs in count two and two now to chuck
nasty
oh comes up and in perfect spot for
urias two strikeouts in the first inning
those bugaboos not here tonight ryan
castellani this young man he'll have his
hands full
this is a clone of one max scherzer
that's the pitch he likes for lux
comes inside jams lux who can only
lift it to short where arenado was
shaded over there's one away the dodgers
shortstop is reached base safely in 14
consecutive games but he's not just
getting on base he is barreling up
baseball's nonstop that one hit hard to
left tapia drifting back running out of
room cory singer's done it again he gets
the home team started with a homer to
left field corey seeger is having a
special year here's max muncie
and muncie draws a walk
2-2 shallow center field drifting
backwards story he's got a glove on it
two away let's watch aj pollock for the
first time tonight elias diaz knew it
strike three to get out of the first
inning but corey seeger a solo blast to
left field one out base hit
josh fuentes hit well the left
did you
yes he did 2-1 colorado this has got to
feel good for not only mr fuentes but
that dugout that you could hear getting
pretty rowdy diaz
waltz on over to second base there's
strike three from top you part of that
phenomenal 2016 draft class for la's
will smith 2-2 at the bottom of the zone
ball three ryan's got to have that pitch
is the low part of the strike zone that
every pitcher wants to have smith
gets into the 3-2 pitch driven to right
center field pilar back at the wall did
he get it
no
home run will smith and we're tied at
two
that's the difference right there
between getting called strike three and
getting another chance well that chance
tied the game up taylor draws a walk
baby bounced over to third rocky's
trying to turn it and they do
i shouldn't act surprised because that's
just colorado rocky baseball but that's
good baseball you hit it to the wrong
guy when you hit it to aronado and even
as strange of a play as that was he made
it look fairly routine so back-to-back
walks work by l.a cody bellinger
fly out bellinger swings at the first
pitch rip to right blackman catches it
goes back to first to try and double up
muncie can't do it but
he does get seeger heads up play by the
rockies right fielder aj pollock against
ryan castellani look at that they're
going the other way
cut
[Applause]
sliding in he's out
so charlie blackman quickly getting it
over to second base beating
pollock great throw
and a really good tag that was close
base steelers now six for six this year
against judeas
to the opposite field with hamson's
speed that's going to be no problem a
tie-breaking knock by the lead-off
batter of colorado coronado two for
eights against floro in his career
that's hit hard into left field
aronado makes it 4-2 rocks [ __ ]
hernandez for the lead-off double
castellani will stay in to face corey
seeger homer off of him in the first
seeger smack to right field he's homered
again
a two-run shot for the dodgers shortstop
his second dinger the ball game gets us
to 4-4 in the fifth polar moves up to
second base to garrett hampson jason
mcgee
hamson charged into one
that's off the base of the wall pilar
will trot home easily rockies retake the
lead this is the third time that they've
taken the lead against la tonight first
two times they let it slip away chris
taylor the other way did you chris
taylor
puts the dodgers on top again i'll tell
you what ball is jumping dory does move
up to third but not two away lefty just
won for 21 against calaric this season
down the line fair ball bellinger's got
a hustle to the bag he beats blackmail
so another runner stranded by adam
colerick you like some late dramatic
story lines matt kemp hitting a go ahead
home run that would fit the
[Music]
the tying runs on second the winning
runs on first here comes corey seeger
bouncer over to second busting down the
line he cannot beat the throw from
hanson the rockies hang on